bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi domenica andiamo avanti con happy
with mi scuso con tutti quanti voi
ragazze in questi quattro giorni non ho
fatto vi do ma da oggi si riparte
normalmente quindi ragazzi voglio
veramente scusare con voi per questi
quattro giorni che sono andata a praga
non ho potuto farli ma vi assicuro che
da adesso in avanti o delle serie ho
scelto già tutte le serie nuove tutte e
ve lo assicuro che non vi aspetterete
mai quello che ho in mente non melo non
se lo aspetta nessuno come lo
immaginereste mai quindi non posso
neanche a spiegare comunque direi di
finire con la premessa secolare come al
solito andiamo su il primo livello di
oggi che slow motion ok il primo il
primo in generale vai sono commedie sono
addio che cazzo sono diventate un
unicorno vinto ma che un rinoceronte al
contrario anche vabbé non importa restar
chiamo voglio capire che cazzo devo fare
se l'ho preso ma che cazzo è successo ok
raga partiamo letteralmente di merda ma
non importa andiamo avanti
ok mi sento carico finisce ma cosa vuol
dire addio sono con sti invece il padre
di uk che e mezzo stordito cosa devo
fare devo lanciarlo su ok perfetto devo
lanciarlo così friendship cosa cazzo
preso ma no sono diventati amici il
padre di gli occhi estive mi fa piacere
ma io lo devo a massacrare quello
stronzo
devo buttarlo giù brutalità brutality
massacrarlo di botte se vai cos'è cos'è
sta roba
madonna cherokee che ti fa una pippa
steve ce la fate micah p noi adesso devo
provarli tutti perché devo vedere che
cazzo di cose si è inventato quello che
ha fatto soli fatality mai cosa ma cos'è
cos'è cos'è sta roba
[Musica]
c'è giochiamo a calcio tranquillamente
con la testa nel padre di yoox save the
watermelon ok questo mi ispira un casino
il nome devo salvare il melone voi no le
braccia bac kat
cos'è io if you have 6 vedevo terreno
che non ce l'ho fatta perfetto è il
cuore di meloni olè olè olè olè olè ce
l'ho fatta
eccolo madonna ma ma neanche oh mio dio
è stato etico
raga fantas è di eddy severamente mito
anche oggi grazie ad eddy l'associazione
save the watermelon è riuscito a salvare
un povero melone indifeso andiamo con
l'io che suo padre che oggi ancora non
li ho tirati fuori e devo andare dove
andare a sinistra si va ai perfetto non
ci passo cazzo non ci devo andare allora
fai tu luke cazzo di oc non
stuprare tuo padre luke nostro cosa mi
prendi la testa maledetto stronzo non
puoi giocare con la mia testa
maledizione ma te la palla va
bè raga direi di provare lo stesso ad
andare avanti ok ci siamo mai luke
baille gli occhi fai vedere chi sennò
cazzo ma così o mio dio è stato tragico
praticamente la mia testa si è data al
bungee jumping devo riuscire a farcela
senza fare la figura dell'idiota vai vai
se ok ciao vai così oh mio dio
fantastico se ce la sto facendo è un
caso no madonna da kurt weill york ci
sei ancora ma mi deludi maledizione mi
delude devo riuscire a farcela
che cazzo madonna che fronte flip
ma veramente un backflip ma chi se ne
frega ma gli occhi aperti o dio è
tornato in sella luke anche se no
partito è tornato se no questa ragazza è
da vedere
guardate guardate liuc guardate
attentamente luke raga c'è parte e poi
lo ri figlio cosa cazzo
epic rock swing per ragazzi siamo vaia
di credo in te vai a di così
madonna che che cazzo che salto senza
casa e vai con o senza testa senza casco
andava bene senza testa un po meno ma
vabbè primo tentativo e così chi se ne
frega vai o no
cazzo il secondo andato devo riuscire a
fare una figura meno di merda possibile
perché no cos'è mi è rimasta incastrata
la testa ma sì oggi ragala le teste non
vanno bene niente
raga oggi con le teste ci facciamo a
cazzotti non c'è verso ma dopo dio
cos'era
nuova ragazza l'acrobazia era veramente
fantastica c'è solo è di fa ste cose
cioè non c'è verso perfetto
cosa devo andare avanti ok no mi sono mi
sono spezzato la spina dorsale
maledizione mai come sto guidando mezzo
ubriaco non informadonna cioè oddio
questa società mi è rimasta la gamba
incastrata nella ruota posteriore non
era un braccio ma non importa mai mi
dovete spiegare come fa uno a guidare in
queste condizioni c'è già una gamba in
bocca praticamente che cazzo fa
vabbè io io non voglio non voglio far
domande mi stacco vai
ok ci sono cosa devo fare che devo
mettermi così perfetto mai grandissima e
di grandi così et madonna che freestyler
vai vai vai sì o dio mio no non ora i
sikh madonna e di non ci credo modo
cieco come ho finito c'è questo è stato
il miglior rock swing di sempre la
ragazza puntata sta uscendo un qualcosa
di epico super hard boiled laura ga devo
assolutamente farlo come in ogni
episodio ci vuole un po troppo
all'indietro cazzo cioè siamo partiti di
merda praticamente due palle non
fraintendete tre palle i tanti mi devo
riuscire
ok no cazzo babbo natale cielo quasi
come si è messo gli occhi c'è ma si può
vabbè hai uno strano modo di giocare
liuc con le palle ma non importa vai jet
è ok
ditemi ke kazzo significa al jazz no no
se addio no che cazzo
vabbè ci riprova un attimo perché non me
l'aspettavo che mi arrivasse così che ho
tirato troppo forte si madonna
impossibile vincere livello maledizione
sono troppo forte limite alla tua
potenza ho preso il razzo ho preso la
baia di decolla mai è di mai ma le mie
idee mie braccia vi servono
non posso dire alla palla se no ok vice
è così andiamo alla vittoria devo
riuscire maledizione se babbo natale
andato devo riuscire a raggiungere la
vittoria vai
ma che cazzo di vittoria era questa raga
questa merita un pollice in su fate voi
però io questa veramente non so se
riuscirò mai a rifare un buon through
del genere è stato fantastico c'è
presenterà un editor controprova beni
porta allora è di ha fatto il suo dovere
meglio di quanto potessi immaginare
tocca a te tra l'altro lago notato una
cosa ma perché non c'è l'alta infatti
c'è ma io finora ha giocato senza odio
ma cazzo ditemelo giustamente se state
guardando video come cazzo fate a
dirmelo non lo so però vabbè andiamo
avanti fa niente vai cos'è o gare
strisce l'olio è tutta un'altra storia
fantastico vai vai stand by sto cazzo ok
sono ancora sono ancora vivo io sono più
forte delle frecce pazzo madonna nonché
in 300 erano così potenti vai steve vai
così bikemi oddio cazzo hai resistito a
tutte le frecce del mondo non puoi morir
mi così non ci credo
hi fi di madonna ok io non voglio fare
commenti
giudicate voi steve sei un cazzo di mito
raga ne faccio un altro un impulsivo
giusto per vedere se riesco è sempre con
stile voglio secondo ok io questo è
diverso dai soliti che cazzo è perfetto
non era quello che mi immaginavo che
questa è veramente fantastico dice vai
ed i terzi che cazzo di costiero beh
oddio ho visto come cazzo vinto è stato
fatto cioè fatemi capire o mio dio ho
vinto in una maniera inguardabile quindi
raga cerco di trovare lo smog trovo che
mi avete fatto voi e aspetta un secondo
ok ragalo trovato ci sono ok l'ultima
volta si era bloccato me lo ricordo ma
mi è stato detto che è stato corretto
l'errore quindi ce la posso fare o
chiedo race luke nonno ciak steve fake e
di perché non ha il casco è fantastico è
padre di uk e vabbè santa mai ce la
possiamo fare
come faccio a prenderlo santa non lo so
allora mappa per farvi jazz kg tutti se
un po vj ovviamente ce la farò mai cos'è
allora prima uk come al solito
ok vai cos'è da cazzo bene
prima andato
devo riuscire a ok fantasticando tutto
grande grandissimo vice tepco si no
adesso mi spiegate perchè c'è il padre
di gli occhi canosa il culo del figlio
raga ce la posso fare credere in me come
cazzo è così c'è steve che si fa le
passeggiate sulle sulle punte va beh non
importa va york è perfetto ce l'abbiamo
fatta
devo riuscire a buttare giù il padre di
luca ok fantastico
si è bloccato di nuovo porca non
ce la farò mai
vai vai vai vai vai prima che si
sblocchi vai devo riuscire a madonna ce
la faccio se ce l'ho fatta vai con santa
prima che si blocchi
ho vinto nonostante i blocchi delle
partite ce l'ho fatta lo stesso vice e
siamo con indiana jones devo riuscire a
ce la posso fare ok
è una cosa un po strana sco livello cioè
non è che vai vai madonna piano piano ma
no cazzo sono rimasti incastrato dal
collo poi finta che non ti stia passando
una trave nel collo fai finta di niente
vai cazzo praga e traumatica sta cosa
dry cazzo spenti se ce l'ho fatta
rapido veloce e indolore fantastico
beh una mina no attento sono ancora vivo
sono ancora vivo sono senza una scarpa
l'ho persa basta che sono ancora vivo se
vai così vai così bike o madonna
cos'è ma non c'è una fine c'è soltanto
un teschio maledizione che cambiamo no
motion soccer ok ce la possiamo fare
dopo madonna che gigi che gigi ok no
ma che cazzo sono riuscito a farmi
segnare come un idiota vai madonna che
anche luke ciò che devo parlargli tutte
e due serie scovai la prima traversa
l'ho preso l'ho preda forse l'ho fatta
non fate domande su questo livello
perché non aveva un senso come del resto
tutto quanto è più il driver in fare
l'ultimo corsa ad ostacoli
ok poi ci siamo siamo che olio che il
padre liuc e allora è fan no kat
baiox e difendi il tuo padre grandissimo
devo riuscire a superare suo punto prima
che partano sei grande mammamia
dell'ultimo senza morire neanche una
volta vai
ok devo devo staccarmi dalla bicicletta
che vai cos'è mio dio ce la posso fare
una gamba via chi se ne fotte chi se ne
fotte
devo riuscire a vincere prima della
gamba ragazza va beh non importa tanto
s'è bloccata li vai avanti e se ce l'ho
fatta e stato abbastanza veloce va bene
la gara direi di chiudere qui perché la
voce mi sta letteralmente abbandonando
anche perché un mal di gola della
madonna comunque raga ribadisco che da
adesso in avanti inizieranno tutte le
nuove serie è veramente voi non avete
idea di che cosa ho in mente vi giuro
aspettatevi di tutto per questa cosa non
mi era venuto in mente neanche a me
all'inizio cioè fantastica vedrete
vabbè io direi di chiudere qui il video
in questi quattro giorni di assenza da
youtube non mi ricordo dove cazzo ho
messo il telecomando o imboscato
fantastico eccolo e ancora è ancora lui
fa speriamo funzioni come al solito se
il video è piaciuto lasciato un commento
vi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come non divido trovate nella
descrizione se non siete ancora iscritti
scrivete venne ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video bella ragazzi